you may not have noticed that
nigel farage has quit uh ukip
after 25 years he said the party had
become
too fixated by the anti-muslim policies
of its leader
gerard batten and he criticized mr
baton's appointment
of tommy robinson as an advisor
and gerald batten mep is with me now
welcome
to you so you prefer tommy robinson over
nigel farrell uh well nigel obviously
hasn't read the manifesto that we
published in september because there
aren't any anti-muslim policies in it
and there wouldn't be because we're not
anti-muslim
uh i think that this is mr farage he
tried to engineer
my vote and no consequences against me
in the mep's last week he tried to do
that on sunday
in his nec he failed dismally both times
and i think this is just sal grapes he's
been looking for an excuse to walk away
for two years
and now he's found it tommy robinson
though is a man who's been to prison
several times
including for mortgage fraud he's a man
who trades under aliases
and anybody who's seen him and the
english defense league outside courts
knows that their message to muslim
people in this country is pretty clear
so you are choosing to to associate ukip
the party you and nigel farage created
with him aren't you
first of all they don't say the edl
don't stand outside courts with him
because the edl doesn't exist anymore he
walked away from that a long time ago
i don't know how old i think we're
seeing a lot of videos and if
concerning people with uh real
convictions you've got four of them
sitting over in there in the house of
lords who make laws over us
people have criminal convictions they
then come out of prison they resume
their lives
are we saying that people then can't do
something once they've uh
served their sentence now what i'd
really like to talk about is brexit
because that's why
walter brexit but i do want to come on
to this because you know nigel farrows
is a
very well-known public figure and he has
effectively said he has no confidence
uh in your leadership you're saying yeah
i haven't said that and the only thing
i haven't said that and the membership
no i understand that but
you know i do want to talk a bit more
about mr robinson because frankly
he is a dodgy and unpleasant character
which isn't unpleasant you've obviously
never met him and interviewed him why
don't you
push him i have actually interviewed him
so don't make that allegation that you
know what about
endangering a trial of people
uh accused of very serious sexual crimes
by his misbehavior outside court in the
one in canterbury he pleaded guilty and
he accepted his
that he done the wrong thing the last
one there was no case against him which
is about to see yourself with someone
who does the wrong thing and who
endangers him
if somebody does the wrong thing and
admits it right then isn't that what
we're supposed to do and he's admitted
he did the wrong thing then he's
accepted the blame
and do you agree with him that there is
a kind of whitewash
that we're not being given the details
of uh what is going on in these crimes
and who is responsible we know from a
recent statement from the crown
prosecution service that they were told
the police were told not to investigate
because
this was considered to be people's
lifestyles what i think that tommy wants
to do in the future going
forward is to look at why these crimes
were covered up and to uncover why in
the social services in the police
that they weren't actually investigated
so i think that's quite a useful thing
for him to do and he's going to advise
you on prisons what
what's he got to say he's told me
already about how they're run
the prisoners run the prisons they're
run by prison gangs how drugs have uh
arrived in prison
how prison officers are bribed to bring
in telephones and drugs because they're
so badly that's what he was up to when
he's in prison
i don't think he was in solitary
confinement actually but people were
talking to him through the bars telling
them they're going to kill him
which is why he couldn't eat the food
that was served to him so i think
someone like that and in fact
i like to when i take my advice from
people whether they be prison
officers or police officers i like to
get it first hand from the people at the
front line
okay yeah you're planning on employing
any more ex-convicts
um no not unless the people in the house
and lords are looking for a job well you
do have some meps in the house of lords
uh some mp while some members of the
hazard or sorry getting confused here
um and what's your instructions to them
i mean they will have a vote it won't
actually affect things do you mean on
the brexit dude yeah i to vote against
it we have to dump the deal
it's right because it's we've announced
but this whole thing is an
engineered uh concoction whereby for two
years
otherwise known as a political process
well no i think it's worse than that
they've been working hand in glove with
the european union
to arrive at a situation where you have
a withdrawal agreement that nobody wants
the
believers don't want it the remainers
don't want it they're telling it first
of all it went from being a good deal to
the deal to now the only deal you're
going to get
is that complimentary pulled to peace
afraid we're not leaving they're going
to we're going to continue
under this transition period the
so-called backstop that we can't get out
of because it
we can't have a unilateral right to
withdrawal we're going to continue
paying them lots of money we're going to
continue with open borders
and the whole thing has been concocted
so that the political establishment can
say oh it's far too difficult we can't
leave
so we have to stay in yeah but you're
falling into that trap if you vote
against the deal because maybe that will
happen that would be a political
establishment because
what is the point and britain will
remain what is the point that'll be a
bit of a known goal
what is the point in voting for
something well you haven't really left
anyway well i've been advocating for 25
years
uh long before nigel farrow's got on the
bandwagon by the way it was unilateral
unconditional withdrawal
whereby parliament takes control of the
process and said repeals a 1972 european
community tax as a first step
tells the european union we just left
but don't worry because all eu derived
law remains in place but we're now going
to start amending and appealing it or
repealing it
and we'll tell you how it's going to
work in us in a cooperative and friendly
spirit
what do you think the economic impact of
that would be i think the economy would
boom because i also did a lot of work
over those 25 years on the cost
of the european union to our economy and
the biggest costs are not the money we
hand over is the indirect cost
on farming fishing and over regulation
on business
and professor tim condon a year or two
ago calculated that was
up to 12 percent of gdp now we could
make
enormous savings by not being in we can
generate more trade we can buy cheaper
food but you have to have a house of
the houses of parliament that actually
want to do that
to make it work